it is powerful patriotism
and an almost cult-like loyalty it's
been on display everywhere we'd be will
you join us in the Han yang in the
stadium and extraordinary spectacle
these people have been dancing for well
over an hour it's just drawing to a
close now this is the celebration to
mark what the North Korean sea is a
victory end of the Korean War back in
1953 this picton 60th anniversary and
we've been hearing songs devoted to what
they call the dear leader Kim jong-un
you can see the faces here it's really
very hard to get underneath bit an
establishment these people are as the
votanis Jenny Kim jong-un would like to
think they are but as a human endeavor
almost all of Pyongyang is just a view
from our hotel window off-limits
attempts to reason with the minders fail
will only see what they're permitted to
show us and so by bus we're moved from
one spectacle to another
there's no stopping in between no more
than a glimpse of real life in Pyongyang
just the showcase buildings and huge
monuments and then we're marshaled into
position to film the North Korea they
want us to see
it is undoubtedly impressive but here
are the contradictions performances like
this for a place which has among the
world's worst human rights records with
many tens of thousands in prison camps
the military parades for a country that
struggles to feed its people but those
people aren't here they're in a part of
this complex country that we won't be
seeing Mark Stone Sky News in Pyongyang
North Korea